i'm not saying we're surprised because  we know you're uh just a super strong  player but you're only 15 prague  so are you a little bit surprised  yourself about this first day  um yeah i'm surprised too because  yeah and expect to score uh three points  today  that's fantastic and obviously you are  currently top eight we know the  eighth best players qualify for the  knockout stage so what will be your  focus now going forwards  um i didn't really think about it about  top wait  i just wanted to play my game and i just  enjoyed the games  all right frank congratulations on a  great first day looking forward to see  you back tomorrow  yeah thank you very much thank you so  much